so I guess I'm going to start with the
most important question up front which
is what do they put in the water at Hulu
because between this and prey I'm pretty
impressed with what they're pulling off
I think it's technically what is in the
water at 20th
um at 20th Century it's uh yeah I mean
look uh my exact Jr and asbell the head
of the studio
uh I I think they just really love
movies
um and I think they really like taking
swings and I think
I mean we can talk about this all day
but I you know I I think it's uh
it's a time in our industry where I
think things need to be a little left of
center for people to notice and I I
think they've really embraced it I think
that's why prey is so good is that it's
not it's it's it's it's a straight it's
exactly a predator movie but it's not in
a way that you would have expected or
scene coming and I think that's what
Trachtenberg is so so great at and
um like I'm just I'm just playing
catch-up uh if we get Frozen again uh
just keep talking
um okay yeah just ignore me um so I I
was do you have a big Lego collection I
do
so was that the inspiration for her
having a village
yeah
how large is the Lego how large is the
Lego it's really big it's more I have
toddlers now so it's all in the garage
but I do I and I also buy Legos and kind
of save them for when the kids go to
college and I can build them without
them destroying it
um uh so but I I have like the the
neighbor I have a big neighborhood I
have
Isengard uh Hogwarts uh the Titanic uh
it's it's big
the haunted the elevator
yeah no I I I am saying you have a
problem and I love it
so
what do you think would surprise uh
people to learn about making a movie in
Hollywood jeez
um
that every that it's it's completely
opposite of the last one and this being
the the best experience I I've had
um uh but it's it's very um
I I feel like there's that Simpsons
episode where uh
they returned to Hollywood after
um they have a disaster of a movie and
like the studios all like it's okay come
back welcome to Hollywood where everyone
takes care of each other kind of thing
and it's like that's the great Simpsons
joke and I think that's typically
[Music]
um true of of Hollywood but I've been
really lucky I think and that I've had a
lot of experiences where that has
um the irony hasn't been ironic it's
been there's a lot of people that really
look out and take care of each other I
think you're seeing it now in the in the
two union strikes of of everyone really
banding together and supporting one
another so it can it can be a cutthroat
Biz but I I think people would be
surprised about how
um how nurturing and and and supportive
it can be at the same time so
into the film did you set out to uh make
a movie without dialogue or did you come
up with this idea and as you were
fleshing it out you're like wait a
minute I can do this without dialogue
the latter yeah it was it was a it was a
surprise to me like I think it was
always like an idea that I thought would
be cool
um but I didn't think about it for this
movie until
um there's a scene that I always knew I
was going to write where Brynn looks for
help at a police station I always knew
how that scene was going to
wind up and that scene didn't have uh
dialogue and then I got to that point in
the writing process and I don't um all I
were when I read I just kind of go and
then see where the winds take me and I
kind of know ideas of where I will wind
up and I got to that point and I was
just like
surprise very surprised at the where we
were at
um and then I thought that was a good
sign where that it was
yeah I like an Easter egg more than a
feature it was It was kind of stemmed
out of character and out of obstacle but
it wasn't a selling point it wasn't why
I um
I set out to do it um and then it just
felt like a a cool
a cool a little bit of whipped cream on
it as opposed to the the main event what
was the reaction though at the studio
level uh to the no dialogue was it a
hard seller were they like it was
um we went on to sell it as a package so
it was a script plus myself as a
director plus Caitlyn
um so they they it was always what they
knew getting into it and it was I was
never like a contractual this is the
thing and it was always kind of an
unspoken thing like if we need it we
will use it
um but it never
it really it was you know it it didn't
like I talked so much more about so many
other parts of the movie than than that
element it was so the surprising thing
was that it really did not ever feel
that different than my last movie had so
much talking in it I think I actually
did more ADR on this movie
um
than I did on the the talking movie
um so it really didn't feel any any
different whatsoever one of the things
is that uh you know we're very close to
it being released and nobody knows that
there's no dialogue how no one knew it
existed until like a week ago
well I mean it's just I guess I'm
wondering if it's gonna make it till
opening day but there are screenings on
Monday and Tuesday you know we're doing
a screening I mean it's gonna come out
that people you know
yeah
I
uh I have no you know it's bad it's for
everyone else now it's like I hope uh
my goal was always that it wasn't the
coolest thing about the movie
um and uh that it's it's a cool part of
of the movie
um
but it's you know we're able to pull it
off because we have a lead performance
that's absurdly good
um and and I think it's more for me it's
more about Diva being an insane actress
uh then it is about
you know no no talking or whatever I I
completely agree the no talking is the
cherry on top of everything else yeah
but it's a very tasty Cherry it's a
tasty Cherry yeah it's it's uh you know
we'll see how the next week goes well
fun on Tuesday yeah
100 so was it always this title or did
you almost have something else I never
almost had anything else but it took a
really long time to come up with this
title like I I'm trying to remember if
when we sold it it had this title or not
I think it did it didn't have another
title though but it was for a while it
was just like I know I was showing the
script to people with no
title for a long time it just said
written by Brian Duffield
um
on the on the title page
and then yeah there wasn't another
Contender
um
ever and then I can't remember what
why this one popped into my head
uh but then once it did it was kind of
like oh that's really
um
thematic and on point and I remember I
want the downside of having a movie
called spontaneous is that it was
impossible to find out anything about
the movie because it was such a generic
word
um and so there was a problem that's
like it needs to be like a little bit of
a combinational words that wouldn't be
too common on on Twitter
um and so there's that element too but I
also like that you could do like a you
know like a 50 style poster with it and
there's a for a little bit I debated
having the exclamation mark at the end
but it didn't feel like it was the right
tone of uh the movie but um so no
exclamation mark but I like that it had
like a kind of a 50s sci-fi Vibe uh you
have learned also the art of uh SEO in
Google because when you have a title
that is also other things it is very
hard to rank on Google
I know and it's I always when there's
bands that like have like really like
air
um like it's I I'm like who who Who's
finding like you have to air band like
it seems so hard and so
um I've it this was nice in that I was
like you know it's a common enough
it's not like uh the most esoteric title
but uh it's it's it's a little less
common than a one-word title no 100
um we haven't spoken but I love talking
about editing because it's where it all
comes together so how did it how did the
film change in the editing room and
maybe ways you didn't expect
there's a really big one you should ask
me on Tuesday night
um uh uh that's very very spoilery but
very funny
um too and then beyond that I had a
really wonderful editor Gabe Fleming
um
and that what I love about a an editor
is that they're able to like
see they make the movie their own and
they see the movie and what it should be
and in a way that you can really argue
and now that I have butted heads with
gay but like it was great to have
that extra force that was kind of like I
really feel like the movie is telling us
that we could lose this moment or or
this scene needs to be bigger I'm not
feeling what I need to be feeling in
this scene
so there was just that that you know I
feel like there's always like that a
director has like a desire to like edit
themselves and then every time I work
with
an editor you're like oh that would be
so stupid because they're the they kind
of take ownership of the movie from you
and can kind of tell you what you're too
stupid to realize
um or what you're so used to seeing
um
that they that they realize so I really
valued Gabe on this movie
um and I think for us it was just trying
to make it as Relentless as possible
like really like edge of your seat hold
your breath
but also give Caitlyn and Brynn the
space that you're never like she never
feels like a ragdoll that you're just
kind of bopping around the movie that
you're like this is a really full
dimensional interesting character that I
would probably watch in a movie without
aliens
um but she just happens to be in this
really terrible situation
um so kind of figuring out how to really
keep that pace going but also giving
Caitlin the space to be Caitlyn and then
you're like you have one of the best
actors alive like you don't want her
just running and screaming for 80
minutes you want to see that character
that she's building
um so it's just a lot of
pushing and pulling in that direction to
make sure it felt
fast but that you were giving her the
space to to knock it out of the park so
one of the things about this is you have
to design the aliens language and their
movements yeah how much had you figured
that out in the script and how much was
that being figured out in
post-production once you're like oh I
really got to figure out how they're
gonna move right now
uh less so in post because we had done a
lot of it in in prep too and be you know
we're not a big budget
um
and so you know we definitely were the
kind of movie that like we knew every
shot that had an alien in it way before
we were shooting because they cost money
um so a lot of that too was okay like
these are gonna
you know we we kind of knew what our
parameters were every day on Set uh and
there was some push-pull uh every now
and again but for the most part it was
really we were like okay the alien is
walking here to here and it's at this
pace because the camera needs to do this
um and we can only do four shots in this
scene because we can only afford four
shots in this scene because we have
so much alien in the movie
um and so it really it kind of stemmed
from that so we did a lot of it in in
prep
um and the guys at d-neck were great we
had like a we didn't do mocap for the
animation but we had a mocap day or two
but in prep to just kind of see what
those figures that we designed would do
and a lot came out of that like um
a lot of the the hand motions that are
in the
movie or from that the the way they walk
and and and moves from that and it just
kind of stemmed out of okay let's make
them
feel really intelligent like let's give
them it was really important to me that
the aliens feel like they had a culture
that they had a faith
um and uh
that you know that was something we got
to kind of do a lot of
before the movie and then and then in
post it was just kind of converting on
that yeah I I really appreciated how
smart the aliens were in the film good
cool that would that it's really hard
it's because and one of the things as a
nerd a fellow nerd you get this too
where it's like too smart and you just
get into Star Trek territory they just
become Vulcans
um and and so it was like a really
interesting that was kind of the the
probably the longest part of it was
making them feel smart that they also
felt dangerous
it was it was really really interesting
there's probably some psychological
component to that that I'm not well
versed enough to know in but there are
things where I was like oh if the alien
does this you'll know they're really
smart and then we would try it and then
you're like oh they're in they're in a
different they're in Star Wars they're
in Ahsoka now it's it was really
um really interesting to to kind of
figure out that that balance and I don't
know what that cocktail
is but hopefully it works the movie you
did a great job uh I know people are
gonna dig this cool I'm out of time but
fortunately Tuesday night we are going
to have a much longer conversation yes
we will
uh thank you like seriously uh congrats
on the movie man for real well thank you
so much dude I appreciate it I want to
hear all about Tiff too I was really
jealous you took the uh link later Hawk
photo right
yeah uh I haven't posted the they're
gonna kill me but I haven't posted the
the good photos that was like just a
photo of me with Linkletter and
and even but there are some really good
photos coming that um the one I
was just like I saw and I was like son
of a
yeah they're in that shirt on camera I
said to link letter I haven't posted the
interview yet I go so how do you feel
about somebody wearing a bootleg shirt
to one of your movies you know during an
interview with you it was great did he
love it he did I would lose my I
also interviewed Maya and Ethan and made
them talk about it but anyway listen
I've got a few more interviews I can't
wait but um I can't wait for both of
those movies
yeah uh uh hitman's awesome I
can't wait